وادرك ان الجميع يعملون من اجل ذلك وخلال
لقاءاتي اليوم
ناقشنا قضايا
تتعلق
بمواجهه ارهابي روسيا وتدميرها لبنيتها
التحتيه في مجال الطاقه نحتاج للبقاء على
قيد الحياه في فصل الشتاء وحمايتي شعبنا
ايضا هذه قضيه انسانيه اساسيه في الوقت
الراهن انها تتعلقوا انها مساله باقه
ناقشنا العقوبات ايضا
الارهابي روسيا التي ينبغي محاسبتها لكل
ما قامت به ضدنا ضد شعبنا وتبدا اوروبا
والعالم الحر ومن المهم جدا ان همم يكون
لدينا صيغه للسلام
ونحن
نقدم
مقترحات بشان الخطوات
من اجل ذلك همم
[موسيقى]
لشركائنا امريكيين
اهمهم لاهميه
مواصله الدعم لاوكرانيا والعمل ايضا همم
من اجل الحفاظ على سلامه اوكرانيا وسياده
القانون الدولي نحتاج ايضا
بمجرد تعزيز قدرتنا الدفاعيه في شهور
المقبله لو اريد نقود في تفاصيل ذلك الان
وتتفاهمون ذلك ولكنني ممتن جدا للرئيس
بايدن على اهتمامه بكل هذه القضايا والنصر
لاوكرانيا شكرا جزيلا
سياده الرئيس سوف نتلقى اسئله من المراسل
مع الاكس من اياه اليوس
شكرا يا سيد الرئيس في عام 2022 ترى
تحالفن الدولي لدعم اوكران كيف يمكن
الحفاظ على تماسك هذا تحالف في عام 2023
رئيسكي
واشنطن في هذا اليوم الجميل ما هي رسالتكم
الامريكي
فيسبوك فيسبوك
[موسيقى]
الاتحاد الاوروبي اكثر وحده مما هي عليها
تعلمون ما هو على المحاك الان شركاؤنا
الاوروبيون يدركونا كل الادراك
يتعلق
بهجوم كبير على بلد اوروبي وهم لا يرون
اشارات بان بوتين يرغب في تغيير ذلك
وميثاق الامم المتحده بوتين همم اعتقد انه
سوف يضعف النيته لكنه همم كان سبب في قوه
النيته
اوروبا
كان يتوقع ان تنقسم على نفسها وبدل من ذلك
فهو انتج اوروبا اكثر وحده مع رغبه السويد
وفيليندا فيلمضمام الى النادي ليس لديه اي
شكل
الدعم وفي ما يتعلق بالنيته
من اليابان والكثير من البلدان الاخرى ان
همم
ساقول لك امور بسيطه هي مهمه للغايه بنسبه
لي
واعتقد ان لدينا نفس القيم وكذلك فهمنا
المشترك اللي معنا الحياه رسالتي هي انني
اتمنى لكم السلام واعتقد ان هذا هو الامر
الاكثر اهميه وانتم تدركون ذلك فقط عندما
في يواجه بلادكم حربا عندما تهاجم البلاد
من قبل
الارهاب
وان ترون ابناءكم يكبرون همم ويبلغون سن
الرشته يلتحقون بالجامعه ايضا
اعتقد ان هذه الامور اساسيه
وهذا ما يمكن لان نتمناه لكم واتمنى ايضا
ان تستمروا في دعمنا لينا نحاربوا من اجل
نصرنا المشترك ضد هذا التغيير
هذه هي الحياه الحقيقيه وسوف نفوز ونكسب
هذه المعركه وانا حقيقه ارغب في تحقيق
النصر المشترك شكرا جزيلا
لا ارغب ولكن انا متاكد من ذلك
المتحده جديده
الشخصيه نعم انه صحفي اوكراني نعم
المساعده الامريكيه
هذا صحيح كمان القياده الامريكيه
والمساعده الامريكيه
قويه
ومره اخرى اود ان
اذكركم انه وسرقكم
كانت ستكون في خطر لولا ما تقوم به القوات
المسلحه
سكيتشرز
فقط
يعني ذلك ربما هذا وصف فلسفي
ليس الا
لست ادري
[موسيقى]
تعلم ان بالنسبه لنا جميعا
السلام العادل هو السبيل بالنسبه لي كرئيس
فان السلام العادل ليت ضمنه اي تنازل عن
وحده اراضي بلادي وكذلك تقديم تعويضات
لكل ال-
اضرار التي تسبب به بها العدوان الروسي
انا تحدثت كثيرا عن الاطفال اليوم ولكن
ال ال الاولياء الامور الاباء والامهات
الذين فقدوا ابنائهم على الخطوط الاماميه
ما معنى السلام بالنسبه لهم المال لا يعني
شيئا بالنسبه لهم
ان التعويضات
لا
تداعيات لها هم يفكرون في الثار
هذه ماساه هائل
وكل ما طال امد الحرب وطالع امد العدوان
سيكون هناك عدد اكبر من
الاباء
والامهات الذين سوف يسعون
لصقر لن يكون هناك سلام عادل في حرب فرضت
علينا من قبل هذا الذي لا اعرف كيف اسفه
وانا في البيت الابيض لا استطيع ان نستخدم
مفردات غير ملائمه
هجوم غير انسان
اعتقد
الرؤيا نفسها واعتقد ان اوكرانيا الحره
هو ما نريده نحن نريد من الحرب تنتهي وكما
قلت
يمكن ان تنتهي الحرب لو كان
ليبتون كرامه وقرر الانسحاب لكن ذلك لن
يتحقق الان اذا ماذا بعد
ناقشنا اليوم مساله ضمان نجاح اوكرانيا في
ساحه المعركه لن يتحقق ذلك دون مساعدتنا
ومساعدته
مستعد للحديث لروسيا يجب ان يكون قد كسب
المعركه همم في ساحه القتال واعتقد لا يجب
ان يقلل من تداعيات هذه الحرب على روسيا
والخسائر التي تتكبدتها
وقد شهدتم واعتقد قبل يومين فقط
بوتين يقول بان الامر اصعب بكثير مما
اعتقده كان يعتقنه يمكن ان يكسر النيته
والغرب
انه يمكن ان يرحب به من قبل الشعب
الاوكرانيا
يستطيع ان يفوز بهذه الحرب
سيقرر هذا الرئيس كيف ينهي هذه الحرب
هل هو دوري الان
تفضل
شكرا على السيد الرئيس مرحبا بك السيد
الرئيس
مستشاركم يتحدثون دائما عن اهميه اللقاء
شخصين
ساعتين ونصف في الحديث
بان روسيا لن تقدم على اي اعمال
تصعيديه بعد تسليم بطاريات البيطريات الى
اوكرانيا
فعلا انني
يتعلق بالنظر الى الشخص في عينيه لا يمكن
يكون هناك اي بديل للقاءات الشخصيه مع
الاصدقاء او الخصوم والنظر اليهم في
اعينهم وهذا تحديدا ما يحدث في هذه
اللحظات وق ان ذلك اكثر من مره وسنواصل
ذلك مره
بوتن همم قيل بانه سوف يستهدف المدنيين
اكثر
الاطفال
والدور الايتام لكنها سوف يخفق في ذلك قد
فشل حتى لانه يدرك انه لا يمكن ان يسيطر
على كافه الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وبالتالي هو فشل في ما مضى ومن المهم
بالنسبه له
ان يروا ان الرئيس
متحده لضمان انه لن
ينتصر قد اخته ولكن اني اقيم كل قائد بما
يقوله
الاتساقط كلامه ولكن هذا الرجل همم
فيما يقول هو واضح هو يريد ان يمنح الحياه
لي همم
وكل من رفقه في هذه الزياره اذا المهم
بالنسبه لي لا هو ان يدرك اننا سنبذل
القصار جهدنا لضماني نجاحي شكرا ما هو
الجزء الثاني من سؤال لك
كيف
تقيم المتحده
تداعيات ارسال البطاريات باتيوتيلا
اوكرانيا لم اناقش هذا الامر اطلاقا مع
الرئيس نحن ارسلنا منظومه ومنظومه دفاعيه
هذه ليست خطوه تصعيديه وانما دفاعيه همم
طبعا نحن نفضل ان يتم الاستخدام هذه
الاسلحه او شريط ان يتم وقف الهجمات
الاشرت من قبل انكم رغبتم في القيام بهذه
الزياره منذ فتره لا لماذا اخترتم هذا
التوقيت وهل لك ان تحدثني عن رساله التي
توجهها لرئيس بوتين مع العلم انكم كنتم
على الارض قبل 24 ساعه